[Musica]
buonasera
ok vi racconto di quand'ero ragazza e
avevo un blog
intanto questa parola un po mimì mimì mi
repelle non so se avete mai sentito
qualcuno a cui avete chiesto di che cosa
ti occupi cosa fai qual è il tuo lavoro
io sono un blogger dovreste indicargli
la porta d'uscita però all'epoca il blog
era l'unica possibilità che avevano per
fortuna i giovani scrittori per piazzare
dentro tutta la propria produzione e
renderla pubblica senza intermediari
senza padroni che dicessero no guarda
questa me la fai un po più birbone
questa me la fai un po più sexy eccetera
e quindi mi sentivo fortunata ad avere
questa piattaforma estremamente
democratica soltanto che nella mia vita
io c'ero sempre messa tutta per
rovinarmi le cose belle e questo blog
aveva è ancora un nome un po vergognoso
madame p p
si chiama così madame p p madame p p è
la signora del led che si occupa delle
pulizie degli spazi pubblici in francia
ok generalmente si tratta di di di spazi
congressuali di autogrill
non so come si chiami negli autogrill in
francia comunque noi questa professione
la chiamiamo la donna a proposito di
rispetto del genere femminile ecco in
francia si chiama madame ppi che sono
chic non hanno il bidet
ad ogni modo la cosa che mi divertiva e
mi deliziava di questo questo nomignolo
di questo pseudonimo
in realtà erano due le cose che che che
mi garbavano i motivi per cui lo scelsi
però oggi me ne pento
il primo è che realmente desideravo che
i miei lettori si immaginasse roque
raccontare proprio quelle storie lì un
po bizzarre satiriche umoristiche come
le volete chiama ecco fosse proprio la
madame p p questa signora che abbiamo
incontrato nella nostra vita incontriamo
tutti i giorni
basta fare un viaggio taciturna per ovvi
motivi perché nessuno se la fila con il
suo tavolino sul piattino con le monete
magari un camice silenziosa giusto si
potrebbe essere ma anche con un occhio
volto all'indagine sociale perché se sei
lì tutti i giorni per otto ore
beh ti vedi passare fiumi e fiumi di
gente gente fichissima con delle vite
super cool restare in tema che scende
giù nei bassifondi ad espletare questo
vergognoso esercizio della pipì per poi
tornare su ed essere fichissimi e far
finta di non avere necessità
fisiologiche perché di questo si tratta
tutte persone apparentemente normali
come siamo noi soggetti perfetti per un
racconto satirico perché proprio quando
uno è normale e anzi quando è una super
cool è lì che le cose finiranno mai
o saranno divertenti che poi per me è la
stessa cosa ma comunque l'altro motivo
per cui mi piaceva questo questo
pseudonimo e proprio l'accoppiata di
madame epp insieme madame cosa vi fa
pensare a una signora altolocata
aristocratica con la sua nobiltà d'animo
non per forza di portafoglio ecco un
nome così tam io lo associo alla
grammatica e tanto mi ha fatto penare la
grammatica italiana
parlo per la mia lingua che è quella che
conosco meglio una cosa talmente bella
talmente altamente nobile che quasi ci
domandiamo come il nostro paese si è
ridotto in un certo modo avendo creato
questa leggiadria grammaticale e una
grammatica di cui all'epoca così come
oggi nel mio lavoro cercavo timidamente
di andare insomma alla ricerca la
riscoperta la riqualificazione uso un
termine che adesso va molto di moda la
riqualificazione della drammatica
italiana l'utilizzo di questi termini
che quando uso mi guardano e mi dicono
sei sicura di avere meno di 40 anni di
cirsu ma credo sia necessario la
riqualificazione della grammatica prima
che si estingua in un epoca in un
periodo storico in cui ci scriviamo
perché con l'aics con la k
ecco questi erano un po i motivi per cui
i minimi mi interessava questo questo
blog
non so perché vi stia raccontando queste
cose schifosissime è un po mi vergogno
però poi quando qualche mese fa i
ragazzi del ted mi chiamarono mi dissero
arianna guarda il tema quest'anno è la
stanza delle meraviglie
io andai a ritroso a ricordarmi i miei
tempi della scuola ai tempi della scuola
cosa ti insegnano che la stanza delle
meraviglie si chiama
anche i capi netto delle meraviglie
quindi non potevano raccontarvi questo
piccolo preambolo di vita personale
anche perché sono profondamente persuasa
che il gabinetto sia una potentissima
metafora della vita umana
peraltro positiva perché la stanza da
bagno è l'unico luogo dove ormai siamo
per fortuna abbiamo il permesso diciamo
di mostrarci ancora umani e l'unico
pensiamoci bene
condividiamo tutto siamo dei drogati di
condivisione non abbiamo vergogna a
pubblicare delle cose in rete
insomma di cui a volte ci si dovrebbe
vergognare pubblichiamo tutto senza
ritegno appunto senza limite senza
vergogna ritegno limite vergogna per me
sono delle delle cose positive
ormai non ci vergogniamo di pubblicare
la foto di noi stessi dentro al letto
appena svegli non ci vergogniamo di
pubblicare che ne so non ci vergogniamo
di fotografarci in costume e di
pubblicare la nostra foto in costume da
qualche anno che mi vergogno però
comunque perché secondo voi tutta questa
fame di condivisione non è forse il
contesto per chiederselo
però vorrei chiedervi perché secondo voi
la maggior parte delle pensione invece
abbia il limite per fortuna ancora di
non voler pubblicare un proprio selphy
l'autoscatto come si chiamava i miei
tempi al gabinetto seduto sulla tazza la
maggior parte di noi si vergogna per
fortuna o purtroppo non so se si tratti
di coraggio di cattivo
perché qualcuno io ho visto che comunque
oltrepassato il limite visto delle foto
di questo tipo sono anche per sosa che
non sia effettivamente cattivo gusto
quello lì perché in questo momento in
rete in tutto il mondo ci sono senza
dubbio tantissime persone che stanno
pubblicando delle cose molto più di
cattivo gusto è molto più pericolose di
un sexy al cesso
il punto è perché la maggior parte delle
persone a questo timore questa referenza
per questa stanza io credo che il motivo
sia molto semplice e banale perché è
l'unico luogo dove ancora riusciamo ad
essere non soltanto umani ma fragili ed
indifesi agility indifesi non sono delle
parolacce anche queste sono delle cose
che possono capitare ed è bello che
capitino restiamo un attimo mettiamo una
temi in pausa questi argomenti e saliamo
di livello se insomma ci riesco a
livello etimologico che bella
l'etimologia e trasforma delle parole
apparentemente banali delle cose senza
neanche doversi drogare l'etimologia di
gabinetto
purtroppo mi costringe a tornare e
francesi gabinetto viene da cabinet ed è
già più bello lo cabinet piccola stanza
privata vuol dire questo non è
meraviglioso piccola stanza privata
luogo lo dice il vocabolario per fortuna
non lariana dove vengono prese decisioni
ed evacuate sentenze vero giuro non è
roba mia
l'hanno scritta quelli lì ora difatti
nella maggior parte credo dell'occidente
l'utilizzo del termine gabinetto viene
associato normalmente a due questioni il
gabinetto quello di cui abbiamo
tristemente parlato finora quindi il
sanitario
c'è chi c'è l'ha vinta al che c'è la
minima non importa
quali siano i vostri gusti c'è chi
spende 200 euro per uno scovolino queste
sono un'altra cosa e il gabinetto dei
ministri
evitiamo di parlare di politica però
pensate bene ha significato e
significante di questa accoppiata
gabinetto dei ministri come fotografi
perfettamente il momento storico
presente
meglio di così non lo potremmo dire non
c'è bisogno di andare chissà dove
[Applauso]
ora grazie mi togliete minuti preziosi
il terzo gabinetto è proprio quello per
cui siamo qui oggi è il gabinetto delle
meraviglie quella stanza dove fino a
metà ottocento più o meno studiosi
scienziati appassionati collezionisti
gente che aveva i soldi per viaggiare
ritirava conservava e portava appunto
dai suoi viaggi cose meravigliose
bizzarre ma soprattutto inutili
conchiglie e piume e animali strani
impagliati ossa non ben identificate
roba che dici sì bella
l'utilità del gabinetto delle meraviglie
era semplicemente quella di incentivare
sollecitare allenare l'utilizzo alla
meraviglia la curiosità ed è per questo
che il gabinetto oggi si è estinto il
gabinetto delle meraviglie perché non ne
abbiamo più bisogno di curiosità di
voglia di conoscere di voglia di
meravigliarci così come anche di
creatività sembriamo di facciata quelli
creativi ma in realtà a pochissimi di
noi sentono di guadagnare o di essere
soddisfatti attraverso l'utilizzo di
queste tre virtù non ci serve più ci
piovono addosso le informazioni
attraverso la rete possiamo condividere
quel poco che sappiamo e sentirci dotti
dei tuttologi un po in tutto tutte
quelle che erano le virtù che avevamo da
bimbi come diceva prima giustamente
francesca oggi si sono estinte e si
estinguono a partire dall'adolescenza
kill johnston
spero di averlo pronunciato bene è un
signore che in america insegna agli
attori ad improvvisare dopo che gli
attori hanno studiato tommy le maschere
le cose a un certo punto arriva questo
signore dice che lascia pure equilibri
adesso lavora in uno dei suoi libri
sull'improvvisazione questo signore
parte da una intervista che è stata
fatta publique per parlare proprio di
questo concetto di come siano importanti
sia importante riqualificare delle virtù
infantili kubrick
intervistato da un signore che lo guarda
gli dice maestro ci spieghi il segreto
dell'utilizzo della della della luce nei
suoi set
perché è pazzesca e kubrick risponde non
lo so è la prima volta che vedo fare
delle luci in un set
kubrick esattamente come johnston non
voleva certo sollecitare le persone ad
essere ignoranti e a non studiare mari
cristina re quell'arte di ri trovarsi
impreparati perché quella che ci
consente di meravigliarci difatti tutte
queste virtù che vi ho citato sono
sollecitate sono sovrastimate
probabilmente quando siamo bambini
se sei un bambino su 6 indifeso fragile
e il tuo lavoro sei un bambino 6
creativo non lo sei abbastanza i bimbi
stanno sempre con un foglio bianco i
pennarelli in mano proprio per
sollecitarli a muovere il disordine
creativo
poi arriva l'adolescenza sa che ti sega
le gambe creative con una mannaia
perché chiedetelo a qualsiasi ragazzo di
14 anni
ditegli perché domani non vai a scuola
non scrivi una poesia e non la legge in
classe a tutti i tuoi coetanei semplice
perché sarà preso come uno sfigato come
un perdente mostrarsi creativi
esattamente come mostrarsi fragili e
indifesi presuppone appunto una
confessione e cioè che siamo umani e
queste necessità fisiologiche non ci
piacciono
quindi per concludere visto che il tempo
sta lì russo questa cosa mi mette sempre
un sacco di ansie ma qualsiasi cosa mi
mette ansia
l'invito è a riqualificare il nostro
gabinetto delle meraviglie c'è ce
l'abbiamo e roba antica e quando eravamo
bimbi
vi faccio un esempio io come credo la
maggior parte di voi quando eravamo
bambini ecco ci si metteva sotto le
coperte con gli occhi aperti al buio e
si formavano tutti questi questi disegni
strani non so se se già all'epoca
insomma facevo delle allucinazioni ma il
punto è che ci sono tantissime cose
inspiegabili che arricchiscono la nostra
crescita ed è brutto dimenticarsene
perché poi queste cose si estinguono è
bello invece riqualificarle per poterle
applicare ai nostri contesti di adulti
perché oggi il nostro contesto estremo
bisogno di persone indifese creative che
sappiano meravigliarsi
e come si fa oggi a meravigliarci che
come aprì la porta ti arrivano gli
schiaffi e devi essere fichissimo
semplice chiudendoci in bagno sì sì
chiudendoci nel gabinetto delle
meraviglie abbiamo un monolocale
non abbiamo tempo modo spazio né soldi
per ritagliarci una camera tutta nostra
chiusa a doppia mandata dove
riqualificare le nostre cose esplorarle
ricordarci come eravamo da bambini
prendere quelle cosine lì che ci servono
e rigiocarci facciamo lo utilizziamo la
nostra stanza immaginaria se ci troviamo
al lavoro se guidiamo un camion
se siamo al giardinetto con il cane
estraniamo c facciamoci prendere per dei
cretini
se quello è l'unico modo che abbiamo di
prenderci del tempo per noi stessi
è un mondo in cui possiamo condividere
io vi dico ok per essere bravi a
condividere e per far sì che la
condivisione sia potente serve ritirarsi
e recuperare quel tempo perduto quindi
chiudiamo la porta per qualche minuto
in questo modo ripristiniamo con le
vecchie cose lì cataloghiamo le
selezioniamo quello che ci serve ed
evacuiamo ciò che non ci serve e
spingiamo tossine e in questo modo
potremo uscire purificati e questo
sostanzialmente il mondo ha bisogno
proviamo a farlo alleniamoci a questo
tipo di cosa se ci provate questa sera
nella vostra casa o rientrando
chiudetevi bene a chiave per qualche
minuto e ricordatevi si bussa qualcuno
basterà dire è occupato grazie
[Applauso]